crime you know that thing that was
almost solved by a flasher dog in the
1980s but specifically these stories
about how we increasingly solve crimes
using forensic evidence it's that thing
that is just a staple of TV crime shows
pull it from the torso on the Left
bullet from the boat on the right to
hearts beat as one
that's how perfectly that's a match we
got a match and they just found the
matching visible match we've a match
match were you able to determine which
monkey bit him the bite marks matched
those of the monkey found at the scene
Wow that last one was presumably from
one of the crossover episodes where the
team from Law & Order worked a case with
the cast of monkey law and monkey order
but but on TV and in real life forensic
science plays an important role in
criminal convictions prosecutors often
complain about a so called CSI effect
where jurors expect to see forensic
evidence in every case the problem is
not all forensic science is as reliable
as we've become accustomed to believe a
report in 2009 by the National Academy
of Sciences found that many forensic
sciences do not meet the fundamental
requirements of science and a report
last year by a presidential science
council agreed saying that expert
witnesses have often overstated the
value of their evidence going far beyond
what the relevant science can justify
and that's the thing here it's not that
all forensic science is bad because it's
not but too often its reliability is
dangerously overstated and one sign of
that is that forensic experts in court
are often nudge to use one very
convincing phrase to a reasonable degree
of scientific certainty toward a
reasonable degree of scientific
certainty within a reasonable scientific
certainty to a reasonable degree of
scientific certainty are you able to say
that within a reasonable degree of
scientific certainty yes and here's the
thing that phrase does have a persuasive
ring to it unfortunately as that
presidential counsel pointed out it has
no generally accepted meaning in science
it's one of those terms like basic or
trill
that has no commonly understood
definition am i trill is that good or
bad I mean I do feel trills so I'm
guessing it's awful and when bad science
is confidently presented terrible
convictions can happen in fact among the
hundreds of people who've been
exonerated by DNA testing since 1989 in
nearly half of their cases there was
some misapplication of forensic science
and there are people behind those
numbers take sant a triple who was
convicted of murder and served 26 years
in large part thanks to an FBI analyst
who testified that his hair matched
hairs found at the scene and as he will
tell you the evidence was presented as
being rock solid
they say they match my hair and our
microscopical Karrde wrists and that's
the way they presented it to the jury
and the jury took it for granted that
that was my hair you know I can see why
they did because who other than an FBI
expert would possibly know that much
about hair except of course whoever
stalled Amanda Seyfried at the 2009
Oscars breathtaking waves without losing
any of their body or bounced stunning
[Applause]
stunning stunning stunning stunning
stunning stunning good
Joris in tribbles case were actually
told there was one chance in ten million
that it could be someone else's hair and
guess what he was exonerated because
once DNA analysis became available his
lawyer tested the 13 hairs from the case
and not only were none of them his some
of what they found was incredible nine
of the hairs had come from the same
source
a couple had come from different sources
and one was a dog two different FBI
agents who had looked at that analyzed
it didn't recognize that it was dog hair
it was a canine it was a domestic dog
yes my personal conclusion was the dog
committed the crime okay so first it is
amazing that he is able to laugh at that
but second if a dog did commit the crime
there's really no recourse there because
there is actually no law against dogs
committing murder and that's the fact
that I learned in Air Bud nine the
police and it turns out Tribble is not
the only case where FBI experts
overstated their confidence in their
results the Innocence Project and the
National Association of criminal defense
lawyers found from the 1970s through
1999 in 268 cases where FBI hair
analysis led to a conviction 257 or 96
percent of them had errors in analysis
oh it gets worse because nine of those
defendants had already been executed
which is horrifying and you would expect
FBI hair analysis to have a higher rate
of accuracy than your friends hair
analysis of you can totally pull off
bangs because you can't you absolutely
can't believe me I couldn't just learn
learn from my mistakes kids
yourselves it's too late for me and look
it's quite no means just microscopic
hair comparison which has had the
reliability of his results overstated
those reports that I showed earlier
suggest there is weak scientific support
for some aspects of techniques like
blood pattern Footwear firearm and bite
mark analysis and you must be familiar
with that last one from cool scenes like
this a little 3d magic for clarity and I
give you the killer's incisors
oh no the computer rated it yellow
rectangle and we all know yellow
rectangle is the highest level of match
a computer can give you about teeth look
in the real world bite mark analysis is
highly subjective and unreliable the
President's Council found the entire
discipline does not meet the scientific
standards for foundational validity
which I believe is science speak for
but people have been sent to
prison on the basis of bite mark
testimony by experts like dr. Michael
West the science of bite marks analysis
is very accurate when it comes to bite
marks West considers himself the maestro
he's found bite marks on a decomposed
body submerged in a swamp on a corpse
that had been buried for more than a
year
he's even used a bite mark taken out of
a bologna sandwich to get a conviction
now that sounds impressive matching a
killers teeth to a bite mark in a
bologna sandwich although you should
know that the defendant in that case got
a new trial after an autopsy report
found that the murder victim had
actually eaten a small amount of Bologna
consistent with the amounts bitten off
the sandwich so that sandwich was
irrelevant to the case in fact you could
even argue that it was actually dr. West
who was full of say it with me
and that is not the only issue that
has arisen from his testimony there are
now five cases where he testified for
the prosecution and whether charges were
dropped or the conviction was later
overturned and even West himself has
admitted that he no longer believes in
bite mark analysis for identifying
perpetrators and he doesn't think it
should be used in court and yet
incredibly every time a defendant has
challenged its validity the court has
ruled it admissible and a key reason for
that is that judges often rely on
precedent to decide what to allow in
front of a jury so if a particular
discipline has been in court before it
is likely that a judge will admit it
again all of which means that as the
co-founder of the Innocence Project
points out decisions about the validity
of science are being made by people who
don't necessarily know much about it
historically we had a situation where
two scientifically illiterate lawyers
argue the bona fides of scientific
evidence for a scientifically illiterate
judge
the twelve scientifically illiterate
jurors could decide the weight of that
evidence and if you think about it
that's absolutely terrifying trials can
often be a situation when no one really
knows what they're doing it's like a
cooking competition for toddlers hosted
by a stray cat and judged by goats oh
the tuna was undercooked and covered in
cold spaghetti sauce you then for some
reason covered the whole dish in honey
nut cheerios I loved it look not none of
this is to say that there is not
reliable forensic science out there
fingerprints and DNA are obvious
examples but while we think of them as
perfect it is important to know they are
by no means infallible the FBI's found
fingerprint analysis could have a false
positive rate as high as one error in
three hundred and six cases and a
dramatic example of this came off the
Madrid train bombings in 2004 when the
FBI arrested this Oregon man Brandon
Mayfield's he had never even been to
Spain in his life but three separate
examiner's matched his fingerprints to
want on a bag of detonators so he was at
that point completely until
investigators happen to determined that
that fingerprint actually also matched
someone else who was in Spain at the
time and that blew the minds of
fingerprint experts we always assume
that fingerprints are very very unique
but what the Mayfield case demonstrates
is that parts of a fingerprint can be so
similar it's possible for two people to
be identified to one latent print that's
true it turns out that two people can
have fingerprints that are so close that
even experts can't tell them apart
meaning that we are now this close to
finally proving my theory that there is
only one Olsen twin she's just losing 30
fast back-and-forth she can
he's right now I don't know how this new
information helps me yet but when it
does the end is nigh you fraud you fraud
[Applause]
and then then there is DNA which is the
gold standard in forensic science for a
reason because in perfect conditions
it's seen as the most reliable form of
evidence but not all DNA tests are equal
and crime scenes can produce DNA of
widely varying quality DNA is very
fragile and easily mixed up at a messy
scene so you imagine you come across a
crime scene you may have a pool of blood
but it may not just be one person's
blood right the more contributors to
that that mixture of DNA the more
difficult it is to determine whose DNA
it was whose blood it was exactly it can
be difficult to tell whose blood is
whose in a large pool of blood which is
coincidentally the premise of my new
gang show so you think you can tell
whose blood is whose in a large pool of
blood it premieres on Tuesday night and
apparently it's already been cancelled
but the problem here is lower quality
DNA samples are sometimes presented to
juries as if they are highly reliable in
2003 a prosecutor in a double murder
told the jury that the odds the
defendants DNA matched the glove found
at the scene by chance was one in 1.1
billion so that's pretty strikingly
impressive but it turned out the glove
actually contained at least 3 people's
DNA and a later analysis put the odds
closer to 1 in 2 and you know what
that's close enough isn't it people do
confuse the numbers 1.1 billion and two
all the time that's why I'm always
mistakenly saying that my favorite R&B
group is boys 1.1 billion men and on top
of all of this there is one more factor
that can be impossible to detect and it
concerns the relationship between law
enforcement and the forensic labs
themselves because you would hope that
those labs would work independently
taking in evidence and spitting out
results but many labs work closely with
law enforcement
knowing details of the case that they
are working on which can prejudice their
work even subconsciously sometimes it's
not intentional fraud but rather
something much more inadvertent which is
the kind of
yes that can come from feeling like
you're part of a side part of a team
that you you're part of you're attached
to the prosecution and you want to get
get the bad guy yeah but that's not
their job at all they are supposed to be
neutral if a referee started
participating in a team's endzone
celebration you'd have some serious
questions like why have you
picked a site and how long have you been
practicing the Dirty Bird
so clearly here a lot needs to be fixed
and some states have stepped up one has
done a lot including passing a
first-of-its-kind
junk science law which which enables
convicts to request a new trial if the
science used to convict them was flawed
and that sounds great and the pioneering
state that did that by the way was Texas
yes I know
Texas you don't expect Texas to lead the
nation in science related criminal
justice reform you expect them to lead
the nation in remembering the Alamo or
naming their children footballs
I love your football but if you ever
forget the Alamo we are done now sadly
at the federal level progress has been
slower although one group the National
Commission on forensic science has tried
to fix that they were founded to advise
the DOJ on how to address many of the
problems than you have seen tonight and
their most recent meeting featured
powerful remarks from Keith Harwood who
spent 33 years in prison for a crime
that he did not commit based on faulty
bite-mark evidence some would say well
you're a free man but I will never be
free of this there's no possibility
excuse me if I get emotional that I
spent more than half my life in prison
behind the opinions in the expert egos
of two odontology there's a death
penalty case in Pennsylvania that's
going on now and the judge is going to
allow bite mark evidence how many people
have to be wrongly convicted before they
realize
that destructs are bogus it's all it's
all made up that's a good question and
it's also the kind of speech that could
really inspire that Commission to do a
lot of good work unfortunately that was
actually their final meeting because the
Commission was shut down in April by
Attorney General and xenophobic boss
baby jeff Sessions and you know what
that shouldn't really surprise you
anyway sessions is a former prosecutor
and he does seem like the kind of guy
who watched dead man walking and was
like hurry up let's kill the guy already
this movie should be called dead man
dilly dallying let's go people let's go
so we may honestly be actively going
backwards on this issue which is
dangerous because not only are innocent
people getting convicted guilty
criminals are being left on the streets
as a result and if this administration
does not see this as a problem then we
should at the very least do more to
educate potential jurors about some of
the shortcomings in our system and one
small way to do that might be this in
this city when the heat rises so does
the murder rate
all right everybody get this stuff back
to the lab eight sheets no need look
what I found
bite-mark bologna sandwich now that's
what I call dead meat is dead meat this
is a murder that's a human person that
is his wife over there
he's a crime solver who doesn't like to
play by the rules I'm getting something
on these bite marks here but it's far
from conclusive would you say there's a
reasonable degree of scientific
certainty no that's meaningless right
and that's a problem for absolutely
everyone around him teeth the hair
matches a victim's wife case closed
slow down microscopic hair comparison is
science chief I ran a
mitochondrial DNA test on those hairs
the wife did it right case closed
actually there were five hairs three
were from a coconut and to your thumb
the light one was from a Cabbage Patch
Kid the remaining one was from the wave
this golden retriever
there's our killer right there chief the
victim was shot how could a dark fire a
gun that's a bad dog right there he's
about to face justice or indoors
you
and he won't stop asking the hard
questions about a certainly reasonable
science degree YouTube no yeah okay
because he's passionate about his job
despite not fully understanding what
that job is if we don't have something
solid by tomorrow
das gonna have my ass why would the DA
have your
we don't work for the DEA what we don't
work for the DEA we do understand that
right please tell us you understand that
well yeah this time totally
oh there's no way he understands that
because this guy will not quit
how about a certainly reasonable stop
talking okay
keep up the good work okay and even when
his team abandons him he's not afraid
that call for backup
this better be good oh it is I brought
in some extra help expert witnesses to
help lock in this case take a look
we got a forensic dentist twin boy
detectives an old-timey prospector with
a divining rod sack full of magic
8-balls
and the counties for most crime sniffing
pony none of this is admissible in court
actually three of them have testified in
court before and they all got
convictions is that the baloney evidence
oh my god see yes I cry see idiot
you
[Applause]